[MUSIC PLAYING]
FOERST: Okay, welcome
to the lecture series
"God and Computer," which
we are running this fall.
Today's the seventh lecture--
the eighth lecture, actually.
And just for the people who
have not been here before,
just to give them a brief
summary of what we did so far,
we started with four lectures
on what does it mean to be human
and what was called
the human factor.
And we heard an
engineering perspective,
a comparative
ethology perspective,
a brain and cognitive
science perspective,
and an AI perspective.
Then we had a part, which we
have today the last lecture of,
personal reports, kind of
case studies on how scientists
from various backgrounds
deal with existential issues
within and outside
of their research.
We had first a Christian
perspective, then
a Buddhist perspective.
Last week, we had a
Jewish perspective.
And today, we have
a Hindu perspective.
And the last two lectures,
both after Thanksgiving,
will deal with how to build it.
Or is it possible to build it?
Next week, we don't
have a lecture
because of Thanksgiving.
And for all people who are
totally unhappy about that,
we have next week a discussion
group, Monday at 12 o'clock
at Harvard Divinity
School, which is 45 Francis
Avenue over at Cambridge.
And the discussion group is run
by Professor Harvey Cox and me.
So for everyone who has
questions about the lecture
series, wants to discuss some
stuff, 12 o'clock, Harvard
Divinity School,
45 Francis Avenue.
I'm happy to answer
every emails.
My email address is A-N-N-E-F--
like forest-- at
A-I dot MIT.edu.
And here are also brochures.
I have a couple of them
outside and a couple
of them inside, including
my email address and all
the other information
you want to perhaps know.
And now I'm very happy and very
glad to welcome Professor Bijoy
Misra here today.
Professor Misra is
physicist originally
and got his PhD in 1977 from
Pune University in India.
He came then to
MIT as a researcher
and worked in the energy lab.
And since 1982, he
has been affiliated
with the Smithsonian
Astrophysical
Observatory and Harvard.
And he is now faculty member for
computer science at the Harvard
Extension School
and also consultant
in the Department of
Radiology and Neurology
at Harvard Medical School.
So already in the science,
there is a variety
of different interests.
But very interested
for this series
is beside all these
scientific interests
is he has a very strong interest
in Hindu tradition and Hindu
religion.
Coming from an orthodox Hindu
background, he works a lot--
he's very, very active in
research on Hindu religion,
Hindu philosophy,
and also Sanskrit
and Indian culture in general.
Right now, he's working on
a high-resolution mapping
of the brain.
And today, he will talk about
the insights from his research
with that project with regard
to his Hindu tradition.
He will focus on Shankara,
whose work he also
has in part translated.
And I think this is a
just wonderful background
in both science and religion.
And so I'm very, very glad.
I'm happy that you
are here today.
And tell us your ideas.
Thanks for coming.
[APPLAUSE]
MISRA: Thank you.
When Anne called me
several months ago
to create a lecture for this
series, I kind of initially
thought that I will
talk with cognition.
Cognition as a topic has
interested me strongly,
because more and more as I grow
older, I believe that we become
prey to perception.
Perception in a sense of
electrical engineering,
that is, where is the signal?
What is the signal?
Do we have a signal?
Can we get the signal?
How much of error is there in
our sights, in our hearing,
in our feeling, in our
overall sensory reception?
How did I come to feel
about this strongly
is different people, scientists,
various enlightened people,
various people with
a lot of information,
will present information
somewhat differently.
That is how I felt that we
must have a good understanding
of perception.
However, when I wanted
to prepare the talk
and then I talked to her
again when she spoke me back,
I said, well-- she
said that, look,
you must speak from
the Hindu perspective.
I said, well, if
Hindu perspective,
I will talk about my
favorite philosopher.
So what you will
hear from me today
is about someone I admire
strongly who lived in India
and whose work I think
has a great importance
in the present-day understanding
of cognition and intelligence.
His name is Shankara.
What I will guide
you through is--
Since it's supposed to be Hindu
talk, so I will kind of first
give you a little
bit of background
about what Hindus think.
And then I will put Shankara
in the Hindu manifold.
The Hindus' ideas
are the following--
Hindu as the word
probably is not very old,
but Indian as a word
probably is more older.
Indian means, like-- India
was called differently before,
but things coming from India.
So a long time ago, I would
say several thousand years ago,
definitely there was a
time where Indians strongly
felt about finding
something called truth.
Now, truth in this
particular point of view,
or a mathematical
point of view--
if you read the scriptures
and literature strongly,
you will find what was bothering
them was something that
has little higher time scale.
Something is not transient.
Something will leave tomorrow.
And tomorrow may be
somewhat like 100 years,
500 years, 1,000 years,
depending upon the philosopher.
This particular
thing, which we'll
call being, which
says something exists.
All right?
That will be called truth.
Something is being.
Now, from that
being, [INAUDIBLE]
create a situational
philosophy of this being,
so basically you have
being and non-being.
And from the beings, things
that are somewhat permanent,
somewhat in the world,
in some stability,
they will create the philosophy,
the fundamental parts
of which philosophy would
be consciousness and nature.
That is, all beings are endowed
with two fundamental qualities,
consciousness and nature.
These are Sanskrit words
which have translated,
but basically they're kind
of close literal translation.
Nature is the property of
the individual, the property
of the being, the way
the being operates,
the way the being
interacts with society,
the way the being interacts
with the environment.
Consciousness is something
that helps him, helps her,
helps it do things.
All right?
So this separation, which has
no metaphysical or godly impetus
in it, was very basic,
that everybody's
endowed with a consciousness
and with a nature.
And nature can be
of diverse manifold,
but consciousness is
a part of the being
in order to activate the nature.
Going somewhat
further, the nature
would have three
different elements.
Nature's manifestation is
the body, the physical body.
That body will have
three different elements.
The first element, intellect,
intelligence, and ego.
Intellect is something that
you are endowed with, genetic.
Intellect is something
that you have less control,
but somehow which
helps you organize,
which helps you obtain things
and accommodate things.
Intelligence is
something that you
do, your cognitive abilities,
your brain activities,
in which you try to manipulate.
You try to obtain.
You try to create.
You try to accommodate.
Or as [INAUDIBLE] says,
you try to assimilate.
Those are all true
for intelligence.
And the third thing is ego.
Ego is who we are,
your own personality.
All right?
Now, ego as you can
see, is a function--
you know, here we have
three different components
of the nature.
And so we have the ego
being the human body itself,
and the human body has
intelligence as a part of it,
which tries to operate, which
tries to make a person move,
make gestures, make speeches,
make movements, eat.
Intellect is
something which helps
them to organize thoughts.
So basically, as you can
see, mind is a part of the--
between the intelligence
and intellect.
And at those points, mind is a--
and original points, mind
becomes a part of intellect.
Now this particular ego can
have several attributes.
Cosmologically--
cosmologically means
if you transcend this particular
theory to a larger scale,
like, the universe
have a consciousness.
The universe has a nature.
Universe has an intellect.
The universe has
an intelligence.
And the universe has an ego.
If we have an ego which
carries our structure,
the universe structure
has its own ego.
From all that point of view, ego
can have five cosmic elements.
This is, again, old.
This is at least 3,000,
4,000-year-old material.
But the point is, to create
a model of the universe
into bringing to
the human psyche
and to create a metaphorical
operation in which we
can understand ourselves
by the universe
was this people's
strong contribution.
The five elements
that I note here
are the sky, air,
fire, water, and earth.
I do not know whether somebody--
what kind of empirical work
went on to standardize this.
Was there any work at
all to say the sky could
be the first element?
But as you will see the
material henceforth,
you will find people
probably did meditate or did
speculate on things and
coming to a conclusion
that if there is a fundamental
element in the universe, that
could be the space.
That could be the void.
That could be the creation
of space between objects.
All right?
I think some people who
are familiar with Hinduism
might also know or might
think that because of that,
they somehow revered sound.
Sound needs the space to move.
So why Hindu people are so
much fascinated with sounds
comes back from these
very, very early thoughts
that the sky, space, becomes
the fundamental element
in the cosmological
universe of the Hindus.
When I say Hindus,
I'm saying the people
who thought in these
lines and which
probably continues to be true,
even at the modern times.
And that's how it
kind of pleases
me to present such material to
and from the cognitive point
of view.
So sky, air, fire,
water, and earth,
in this particular order.
Sky gives rise to air,
air gives rise to fire,
fire gives way to
water, water gives way
to earth in some kind of
a continuous succession.
And that is how the
development takes place.
Now, one these five elements,
which are orthogonal,
or independent, which are
kind of mutually exclusive,
they are-- even though one
originates from the other--
once they are in place, they do
not interact with each other.
They are separate.
And once they are in place,
they could give rise to,
or to carry the message
of each of these elements,
then human beings or the
so-called beings can create,
evolutionary way,
create the sense
organs, our sensory perception.
Our sensory perception,
from this point of view,
is designed because of
the cosmic elements,
sensory perceptions being five
and the elements being five.
There's a one-to-one
relationship
between the sensory perception
and the cosmic element.
Now the sky space carries sound,
and in order to hear sound,
you have ears.
The air carries the
pressure, the molecules,
and in order to get the
feeling of the molecules,
you have the touch
sensation, have the skin.
Similarly, fire
gives you the shape,
the presentation of
material-- the view, so that
gives you the eye.
And then the tongue, the
taste, and the nose, the smell.
So these five organs
can be created.
Once these five
organs are created,
then these philosophers
will go a little further.
And they will say that
human beings are composed
of some more organs,
which are the hands, legs,
the procreation, excretion,
and the speech, the mouth.
And finally, maybe
if you want to have
mind as an exclusive
organ, exclusive element,
you also add mind.
So this is the Hindu universe,
which even [INAUDIBLE] today,
conceived, developed, probably
somehow empirically debated,
maybe 3,000, 4,000 years ago.
But when a person is born,
dies, during his life,
somehow people have
this belief that this
is how the body is
composed of, and this
is how the body will deal with.
The principal part of it, I
must say, in this whole thing,
that all these
so-called developments,
they took place from
the right-hand element,
which is the nature.
The consciousness
did not interact
with all the development.
The consciousness is an entity.
Nature is an entity.
And this nature, through
its own processes,
develops the various elements
and then organs and eventually
beings, and beings become
human beings, and so on.
okay.
If that's so, then what happens?
At this time, they
will think about that
suppose that consciousness
is endowed in all beings,
and they are the guiding
factors in all beings,
so naturally, there is a element
of consciousness in all beings.
This particular thought,
which eventually we
have called soul or something,
which Aristotle accepts--
and I think generally we have
become addicted to a system
that, yes, we have a soul.
And soul is the one
which God [INAUDIBLE]..
The soul is the one which
understands, suffers.
Soul is the one which probably
eventually takes our life
wherever it needs to go.
Some kind of religious
thoughts have
been associated with the soul.
Originally, however, these
people did not think that way.
They thought the soul would be
an element of consciousness.
And because consciousness
does not transform--
oh, by the way, when I say
consciousness and nature,
and from the point of
view of the time scales
I was talking about, all right?
So nature, because it evolves,
it has a shorter time scale,
because these
things evolve, form.
They might change.
But consciousness has a
much, much larger time
scale, most likely
doesn't change at all,
from the original theory.
Now coming back here now,
so the soul would be, then,
an element of consciousness.
And because the
original consciousness
has a very long time scale, the
individual soul's consciousness
will also have a
strong time scale.
What follows because
of that, from the point
of view of the body--
when the body decays, body dies,
this time scale of the soul
is longer than the body.
So it might look as though
the soul is immortal.
It might look as though
the soul doesn't die,
and soul remains
in the universe.
Once created,
doesn't go anywhere.
It stays in the universe.
What does it do?
It becomes what they
call a passive witness.
Why becomes passive?
It's a passive witness, passive
witness because it doesn't act.
I must tell you also
one more thing here.
During this particular
discussion about the Hindu
cosmology, or the time of
these philosophical discourses
on this, the question of
time strongly came in.
And people thought
the definition of time
would be something
that differentiates.
The object is there.
The object has moved.
The position has changed.
See?
There's a different
realization has come in.
And that will kind of
make you feel that as
though some time has elapsed.
So from that point of
view, because the soul
has a long time scale,
so it should not react.
Even though my hand
moves, my mouth
speaks, even though
I have personally
moved, my soul is
not moving with me,
because it operates on
a longer time scale.
All right?
So it basically-- because
of that, it will stay inert.
So once we define this, once we
make this particular framework,
then we come to the experiments
that people have done lately.
And I want to project them
in view of Shankara's work.
Those experiments have shown,
I think, the following.
These are accepted by
the Indian philosophers.
And I think lately the
different experiments
in Europe and this
country have come
to such kind of conclusion.
That is, we do operate
on different brain waves.
We do operate on different
kinds of systematic cognition
on our brain function, depending
upon how we exercise our brain,
depending upon how intensely
the brain is working,
how relaxed the brain is.
The concept that
these people have
from the point of view
of their own thinking
that the consciousness--
which I said soul,
which I said is
a part of universal
consciousness--
may exist in four
quantum states.
One state is as we are, waking,
which is very strongly-- if you
take the brain images, you
will find that the brain
is functioning pretty fast.
Brain is functioning, what,
about 20 cycles of second.
It's kind of very
strongly operating,
because different kinds
of sensory perceptions
are coming to the brain,
different kinds of ideas coming
to the brain, and you
are dealing with all
the different functionalities.
Then you come to the
dream, which kind
of semi-awake, but not really
fully cognizant of everything
that's going on.
You are slept, but
not fully slept.
In that situation, the brain
has slowed down considerably.
It probably has gone down to
about eight cycles a second.
And also, people know that as
you close your eyes and so on,
you can possibly see these
different images, visions,
and so on, which is a part
of the whole cyclic process
the brain goes through when the
brain is somewhat slowed down,
not as compared to the
completely awake state.
Then there are two
other steps, which
are the sleeping
state, which is kind
of the original thought of the
soul that the person is living.
And however, simply
the body is sleeping.
That means that the
person's life is not really
fully gone away.
Person's senses are
not fully gone away.
And the soul is only active.
So in that state, people say--
like we have the delta
wave, which is the one cycle
a second and so on,
which is operating
on your brain functioning.
However, the fourth
state, which I
call the awakened state,
for which these people talk
about very strongly,
and I can't really
give a good example of what an
awakened state might look like,
except I will kind of
comment the following.
I will say that when you
are strongly focused, when
attention is
concentrated, when you
are dealing with a particular
process with utmost sincerity,
where as though your
whole senses are focused
on that particular object, it
is either to rescue a person,
saving your own child, helping
your friend in strong distress,
or being very lonely yourself
on any particular problem,
where you are
deeply to yourself--
so I think such kind of states,
which can happen momentarily
to us, where we don't really get
cognizance of all of our senses
at all, because
they're so focused--
or even for students
and so on when you're
doing your homework
for tomorrow, when
the exam is there and so
on, and you don't really
care what's going on around--
so that could be a state
where you are fully, fully,
fully, fully conscious
of only yourself.
And not receiving this
sensory input from anywhere.
What happens in such situation--
it could be, I think,
no experiments have been done--
would be that probably, you
don't have a wave at all.
You will simply
have a DC current.
You will simply have a situation
where you will have a full--
the brain is functioning,
but brain not
functioning in an
undulating manner,
but brain is functioning
as though it is steady,
as though it is operating
with full attention.
Now, such particular thought,
such particular state, Shankara
will deal very strongly with.
Let me now come to Shankara.
Oh, before I come, I want
to put two more words here,
that in this theory
that we have,
because this consciousness
can be all around us,
consciousness can take two
different manifestations,
or what are called
manifest consciousness,
unmanifest consciousness.
And then people have--
Hindus have called them gods.
Hindus have called them--
you know, like when
somebody has endowed
with strong consciousness,
where he's cognizing everything
easily, quickly, strongly,
has strong values
and so on, they have been
associated with godly nature
in this particular philosophy.
But in general, also, the
confines consciousness
may be all around us, but
doesn't manifest itself
as a physical object.
You see, and you
must understand this,
even though that
consciousness do manifest
as a physical object, it
is not associated itself
with some nature.
And so consciousness
may not manifest at all,
but may be present
all around us.
And that, we can call God.
Or we can call God
something where
an embodiment of
consciousness did take place
and which kind of went through
the normal, natural cycle
controlled by the nature.
So this brings us to our
philosopher friend, Shankara.
Shankara-- who is Shankara?
He lived around 800
AD, a prolific writer.
And what we know so far--
that he's a strong debater.
Debater because when you
make some thoughts which
may be somewhat different than
what the establishment thinks
at a particular
time, some people
might try to argue with you.
So he was probably--
spent most of his time
in debating his views
with the other people.
Most people at that point
were Buddhists, Buddhists
who would not really--
who'll think-- I'll say
what the difference is.
But basically the
difference would
be that whether
our consciousness,
our understanding, our
cognition, our intellect,
is controlled by
us, or our intellect
is controlled by or helped by,
assisted by, a consciousness
which is larger than us.
That's the principal difference.
And as you'll see,
Shankara will argue now
that that particular--
the intellect operates, but
intellect is endowed always
with this blessing of
large consciousness
from which it draws
its resources.
How does it do it?
He defines three terms.
He defines something
called a knower, something
called knowledge,
something called known.
So knower is the actor, the
one which does, one which sees,
one which hears, one which
remembers, one which decides.
So that's the knower.
So in all cognition
process, Shankara
will say that something, a
quantity, called knower exists.
So the question is, can
we find what the knower is
in our body-mind-nature system?
Knowledge is easy.
We know that whenever
we try to know
things or search for things,
or we can search always
for knowledge.
And knowledge we acquire.
But I'll come in a
second where Shankara
will think about knowledge.
And then finally, known.
Known is your
accumulated knowledge.
Known is your decision process.
Known is how much you
can really reach out
to your own consciousness
and knowledge
to associate new objects
into that knowledge.
And this come the
catch, Shankara's catch.
What is Shankara's catch?
It is-- oh, before I do,
that three definitions.
What's the knower?
Knower uses the intellect.
Mind you, again, we have
defined intellect, intelligence,
and ego.
So knower uses intellect.
That we can know.
In order to know anything,
we have to discriminate.
We have to use our collected
knowledge to disseminate,
to decipher what's up there.
What Shankara will
say different, though,
that this particular
cognition is
a superposition of the
consciousness on the intellect.
That is, the intellect is
looking for a solution.
Intellect is looking
for assimilation.
Intellect is looking for adding
the stuff to the accumulated
knowledge.
But intellect is
not sufficiently
aware to find out everything
about the new object.
So unless intellect
is conscious,
intellect will fail to operate.
Intellect is biological.
Intellect's part of nature.
Intellect is part of the body.
And that has to associate itself
with the consciousness in order
to make itself cognize the
object that it receives.
So this is Shankara's
first hypothesis on knower.
Then, knowledge is a
perception of the intellect.
We all perceive.
We all have our own
ideas about things.
So he agrees with that, that
you can have your own theories.
You can have your own feelings
about various objects,
various motions,
various functions.
But he says you have
to then go beyond that
and to see how much of that
knowledge is universal.
Is that knowledge strictly
to yourself, or anybody
else agrees with you?
In order to make that
particular transition,
Shankara will go a very,
very long step forward,
will say that all
knowledge, if they
be classified of knowledge,
they have to be true.
They have to be true.
They must have a value.
They must have a value
which is not transient.
Remember, I said the time scale.
So it would not be a small
time scale operation,
but end knowledge,
if you know it,
has a time scale much larger
than your perception time
scale.
He will say, look, every
time the sensory organs
operating and you are receiving
information, creating images,
you are trying to think
the images are stable
because of persistence, because
of the new image has something
with the old image,
and you did not
distinguish the new
image and the old image.
However, whether
there is truth in it
is a function of if the
image lasts for pretty,
pretty, pretty long time.
And that you can only do
because your intellect is only
operating a short time scale.
You associate that with the
long time scale consciousness
such that you can
see, yes, there
is truth in this particular
feeling, the truth
in this particular
message, the truth
in this particular thought.
Because of this, he will make
this second assertion, that is,
our intellect is not capable
of finding the truth.
Our body intellect is not
capable of finding the truth,
because body intellect is
conditioned by the body
experiences, is conditioned
by the knowledge
that we see before,
is conditioned
by the accumulation of
material that it has received.
Hence, it is not
capable of deciphering
information which
is new to it, which
means when the child starts up,
whether he will start smiling
or crying is a function of
the child's intellect, is
a function of consciousness
which the child's
intellect interacts with.
And then the intellect receives
the message that, look,
smiling is good for you.
Similar hypothesis,
similar hypothesis
that when we have
a decision to make,
our intellect is
incapable of getting
into the depth of the
problem and making us
feel assisted on the problem.
And then the intellect
searches for--
and when the intellect
searches for, it's
the consciousness
which kind of then
helps the intellect, okay, hey,
look, there's the solution.
Now, this consciousness,
whether the intellect
can reach it or not,
that's up to the intellect.
But the theory is that
that consciousness exists,
and intellect can
reach out, all right?
And I'll come in a minute,
how do you reach out?
And then known, so
he will say what's
known is a function of evidence,
is a function of inference,
and function of articulation,
whether you can really
speak it, right?
So known is--
that's kind of easy.
That's easy, because you
know you can always state it.
But then when you say words,
all right, by showing images,
by comparing-- this man is a
man because the man has two legs
and so on, two hand and
stands erect and so on--
so that's like evidence.
But when you say, the man--
I describe this person by
having seen this person,
using words, that gives me a
different kind of cognition,
because I don't know so
much about the person.
I will describe the
person as I see it,
which is not the full story.
And hence, I must be
consciously intellectually
active, blessed with this
overall consciousness
to help me, to stabilize
what I know about the things
so that I can articulate.
So this is the story about the
knower, knowledge, and known.
Then he will say that
because of this dilemma,
that intellect is only limited
by the human experience,
by the human thoughts
or by the human memory.
So the first paradox would be,
we will never know the knower.
In other words, you know that
your intellect functions.
You know that your intellect
helps you understand.
But you do not know how
that intellect functions.
The intellect has
function by virtue
of consciousness, which
has assisted in gaining
the particular cognition.
And because you have no
access to the consciousness,
hence you--
it is beyond the intellect.
And because it's
beyond intellect,
intellect doesn't perceive it.
intellect only feels it.
Shankara's metaphor
is it's like light.
The consciousness is like light.
So light's something
that you don't see,
but you only feel it
when light falls on you.
So it's some kind of
metaphor, similar metaphor,
where he would say that knower
is outside the intellect.
And hence, you are, with
your intellectual energy,
you are not able to.
And because you can't
see it, all cognition
is always incomplete.
All right?
Why is incomplete?
It's incomplete because you
don't know who lets you know.
You have some knowledge.
You did find a solution.
You did complete your
local cognition cycle.
But you did not know how
that consciousness, how
that local cycle
did get complete.
And because of that,
cognition remains.
So then he will hypothesize two
very fundamental hypotheses,
which comes
Shankara's philosophy.
The first one is that
any knowledge that you
ought to know, you
must know the knower.
It is the knower
which helped you
cognize through your
intellect, assisted you.
So if you have any
search for knowledge,
then you search for the knower.
And knowledge is consciousness.
Knower is knowledge,
and knowledge
itself is consciousness.
What it means now-- which means
that every thought, every idea,
every cognition, is endowed
with an intellectual curiosity.
But that curiosity is not
complete till a consciousness--
a conscious effort has
been made to cognize.
And that conscious effort is
not within your discretion,
but it is a pure connection.
It's a pure grace.
It is a pure assistance by
the universal consciousness
onto intellect.
So you know.
So these are the two hypotheses.
Once he has the
hypothesis, I will kind of
say that he'll go
a step further.
And he will say that, look--
he will conclude-- that,
look, you have intelligence.
You know, I titled my talk
"Intelligence and God."
So he will say that, look,
your intelligence guides you
in search of knowledge,
search of knowing things.
But your-- the way you should
guide your intelligence is to--
your intelligence is
in search of knowledge,
but intelligence limited by
your perception and delusion.
Delusion is a word which
we'll use very strongly.
That is, you think you know.
You think you are.
You have cognized the
object completely.
But that's an illusion.
That's it.
You are deluded.
You're deluded because
your body, your senses,
have failed you.
They have kind of
given you an impression
which is a local, transient,
momentary, very short time
scale.
So in order to make a larger
time scale, more permanent,
have stronger, stable
knowledge, you must search more.
And if you search more, then
you try to get the knowledge.
If you get the
knowledge, however, you
can't get the full knowledge
unless you know the knower.
Who is the knower?
He is knowledge.
So the ultimate
knowledge is the knower.
And that-- I did
not use the word--
he will use a word
called Brahman.
So he will say
that, look, there's
only one truth in the universe.
That is this cosmic,
ultimate consciousness
that you call Brahman, which
is pervading every object
everywhere, all over the place.
And then that helps
you intellectually
to gain understanding
of various objects.
What it has to do with
machine intelligence
is the machines will know.
Machines know them objectively.
Machines don't perceive.
Machines tell you
what the facts are.
So we can train the
machines to really go
become smarter and
smarter and then
be consciously
objective, knowledge
being all parts
of consciousness.
So all the knowledge
that we know consciously,
which had been endowed
through consciousness to us,
if we accumulate
together, maybe we
can asymptotically reach
this large consciousness.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
She said I must stop at 5:20
so that I can take questions,
so I stopped.
5:20.
I take questions.
FOERST: Yeah, we have
some time for questions.
Thank you very much.
For me, actually,
that was very new.
I've never did anything with
Hinduism, so I'm fascinated.
And I'm actually
especially fascinated
when I have the right to kind
of ask the first question
or give the first comment.
MISRA: Please do.
Please do.
FOERST: How close that is
to this whole Western idea
of this whole--
first of all, the
whole body-mind split
and the whole
subjectivity-objectivity
dilemma.
MISRA: Yes.
FOERST: And I would like to--
if that's--
MISRA: The point is
it doesn't contradict
what happens the following, like
the modern psychological theory
that, how does our
intelligence operate?
I think I used
those words before.
But it operates in three modes--
assimilation,
accommodation, organization.
Assimilation is a function
of the brain, intellect.
The accommodation is a
function of the mind.
And organization,
function of the memory.
What he's saying, that
these whole three processes,
even though they
look biological,
they are not biological.
They are conscious.
That you are only
limited by your biology,
by your body structure, by
your memory, by your brain,
to receive the knowledge
as much as you can gain,
as much as you
can really obtain.
So what you do is, if you stay
in a so-called awakened state,
where your mind
is fully focused,
where your cognition is
total, at that point,
you will see that the
knowledge that comes to you
is only the pure knowledge.
But what happens, though,
people who have written about it
and people who have probably
reached such a state,
they will say at
that point, you don't
distinguish between objects.
So that's the catch there.
The catch is that
once you have--
you don't have undulations.
When the times become still--
you understand?-- when the
differentiation doesn't exist,
then things become
cognitively indifferent.
And hence you don't have
any physical perception,
because you have
suspend your senses.
So that's the dilemma there.
That is, one can probably
reach such a state,
but you must have some kind of
your natural perception still
continuing so that
you can receive
this so-called understanding
that you are trying to receive.
Otherwise, you are
towards the god,
or you have reached a point
where your senses are not
really important anymore.
The only thing that's
important to you
or has been important to
you only is this flat field
consciousness.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Without
nature, consciousness
is still in existence.
MISRA: Yes.
FOERST: Would you mind repeating
the questions for the--
AUDIENCE: Without nature, can
consciousness still exist?
MISRA: Yes.
AUDIENCE: And I'll ask a
simple question and then--
do you think that what a human
being is capable of knowing,
ultimately capable
of knowing, is
replicable in
artificial intelligence?
MISRA: The answer is yes.
The answer-- that's exactly
at heart, is interesting.
That is, the-- so you
can't say artificial.
You know, I called--
I think I was--
I did not use the
phrase, but I will
call objective intelligence.
We are operating on two modes.
Objective
intelligence, something
with a longer time scale,
which doesn't get refuted.
I see you.
I see you exactly the way
I have seen you before.
So our perception, our reaction,
our interaction between the two
people, will not change in the
next five days, next 10 days,
next 10 years, because
we understand each other.
So that's our cognitive,
reactionary operation
between two
individuals, two beings.
Now once that particular
time scale is shortened--
you go out-- because
I don't know you.
I go out, I say
yes, I saw that guy.
So then what happens
is you are operating on
a lower level, on a
subjective intelligence,
where as a mutual
convenience, but operating on
as though that we have
something to deal with.
We have business.
We have interest.
We have togetherness, which is
smaller compared to the larger
permanence that knowledge
would be all about,
that truth would be all about.
And hence why I like the
machine point of view,
that machines will not change.
Once we train them on the
objective intelligence,
whatever we have
found naturally--
objective intelligence, again,
have their own time scales,
right?
You know, Newton's
laws, relativity.
So things do happen.
So things are not permanent.
But we have some
semi-permanence we can build in.
And hence probably we can create
super smart machines who deal
with that, who are not really
subjectively cognizing,
but objectively cognizing,
who cannot really go--
you know, something
dressed up and so on-- yes,
this looks good.
No.
I know that man.
I know the nature.
And I mean, whatever we
can fool-- that's exactly
Shankara will talk very strongly
that we are subjectively,
all the time, fooling ourselves.
So you have to go inside,
strongly concentrate
who you are, and
then find out you
have a basic, inside of you,
an objective intelligence,
and that is independent of you.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
MISRA: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: You mentioned in
your early part of the lecture
the avenues of universal
[INAUDIBLE] elements,
earth, wind, fire, and water.
Now, in Aristotle's elements,
he describes all these four
elements, except in the
Indian case, you have sky.
MISRA: Sky.
AUDIENCE: Space.
MISRA: Right.
AUDIENCE: And the concept
of emptiness, space
probably is instigator
of the concept of zero
in inventing numerals in India.
What I wanted to ask you--
were either the Greeks--
Greek had interactions with
the Indians at the time.
Alexander the Great,
when he came to India.
Or the Indians were [INAUDIBLE]
independently defied out.
MISRA: I think both
are independently done.
I think the-- because the
Greeks did not know that
much of Sanskrit and so on.
Probably when the Alexander
came to India at that time,
this was probably already
established, the five elements
and so on.
But I don't think he spent
enough time or the interaction
was enough to really
carry this out to--
and by the-- also, by the time--
Aristotle is old by that time.
So I think his material--
he doesn't wait for
Alexander come back
and deliver him material.
And also, space as a concept--
this is all hypothetical,
like whether they
took the five elements and
chopped one and so on because
of the void, and--
but I don't think
that's the case.
I think what--
I think the visible operations--
you can make a cosmology
out of the elements,
Aristotelian elements.
But to think about
space as an element,
to sound as a attribute
to that element--
and human beings
have a speech, have
the fundamentally different
than other objects
to make that happen.
So those are all
metaphysical, which
probably Indians were somewhat
advanced than the Greeks
at that time.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: I can [INAUDIBLE]
remark on both this talk
and the structure of the talks.
MISRA: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: I think
we deal here, is
like two directions of thought.
One is a traditional
thought with
[? general ?] understanding
of the world and also ethical
philosophy that is
called religion.
And that's the same thing
[INAUDIBLE] understand without
data, but it's still our--
more of an ethical attitudes
to things that that's partly,
what [INAUDIBLE] now.
And the other thing
is science, that
is, the [INAUDIBLE] in terms
of motivational structure.
So it's natural to try
to reconcile the two,
but things like recapitulating
the ancient ideas
of cognitive science like
Shankara, Artistotle,
somehow don't do it to me.
MISRA: Don't do what?
AUDIENCE: They-- it's primitive
science, is my opinion.
It's primitive
cognitive science there,
but, of course, it doesn't
appeal to my ethics.
And maybe we can
also sometimes hear
opinions of people who are
not trying to reconcile
those things, but think that--
MISRA: It's primitive because
it's done at old time,
or primitive because
the ideas are--
because it's thousand
years old, it's primitive,
or because you think
that's mundane,
and should not discuss?
AUDIENCE: Neuroscience, how
the brain is really designed--
some of these
things are out of--
MISRA: Because neuroscience
doesn't answer this.
We go back to consciousness.
See, consciousness
is a particular--
that's exactly-- I went to
the brain mapping project.
The consciousness,
if we can find
in your brain what
cells are there
which makes you conscious.
It's not a function of how
you hear or how you see
or how you sense.
It's a function of what
makes you conscious.
Our instruments at
the present time,
our thoughts at
have failed to
even understand how
we synthesize, how
the mind functions,
even from sensory perception.
What you are receiving is
only some kind of sketches.
We're receiving
only small signals.
Remember I said in the beginning
that we have this very, very
sketchy signals that are coming
from different directions
to you.
You are processing them
to create an image.
That processing, how it is
done, which part of the brain
does that, we don't know.
That's the reason why
we are going to make
these five-micron brain map.
Hopefully, we can navigate
and see where it is happening.
Not that I can
guarantee we can see it,
but that's the question.
The question is, we
have all these neurons,
we know how these neurons
are activating themselves,
we know how they are reacting
to different sensory operations,
but we don't know how
they're synthesizing,
if they're synthesizing,
what time scale
they're synthesizing.
And then the question is,
if they're synthesizing,
what happens to the perception
of it, the knowledge of it?
What the consciousness--
you had a good question.
Consciousness could be some
kind of a genetic cell.
That's what I think.
It could be a very minute cell
which probably operates in all
of us in different degrees.
And probably, in some process,
we get activated to it.
Could be.
But you can't deny
the fact that you
are not conscious all the time.
You can't deny the fact that
sometimes you're conscious,
sometimes not conscious.
And your brain doesn't say that.
But the same brain, the
same memory, the same mind,
the same intellect, same body,
same blood, goes unconscious.
That's the question.
It happens in children more.
Yes?
FOERST: No, please,
please go ahead.
I just would like to finish
to answer his second question.
MISRA: Yeah, another question?
FOERST: His second--
No, his second question was--
to the structure of
the lecture series,
I don't try to reconcile
religion and science.
I try to present a variety
of different scientists
and their ways to
deal with these two.
So today Professor Misra
tries to reconcile them.
We had other people who
try to keep them apart.
We have other people who try to
keep them kind of in a balance,
but still--
I've tried to present a variety
of people with different ways.
So it's not an overall objective
goal to bring the two together.
I don't know-- it's
probably your first lecture,
otherwise you--
AUDIENCE: No, I've been
here for multiple talks.
But I would like to hear
two more people, one
who thinks that religion is it
and science doesn't do anything
and its view of the
world is hogwash,
and the other person
who would think
the same thing about religion.
Not people who have both
things and try and--
FOERST: Well, you know, I
tried to invite those people.
But people, if you think
that science is bogus,
are not scientists, and
therefore they wouldn't--
I cannot present them here as
scientists doing that stuff.
And people who hate religion--
I invited several people,
and they all denied to come.
So in that sense, it's--
MISRA: No, if you asked me
what my personal opinion--
religion is bogus.
FOERST: Oh, good.
MISRA: I didn't say
religion at all.
Did I use the word
religion at all?
There's no religion.
It's a question ignorance.
Ignorance to the
point that you use
the perception, and perception
for a short time scale.
I don't know-- what's your--
you are a physicist,
chemist, computer scientist?
Yeah.
So time scale.
We're talking about cosmology.
We're talking about how
the universe begins.
How does the universe
sustain itself?
Do the laws that we think are
true here are true elsewhere?
Are they true in you and in me?
If not, why not?
What we are talking consciously,
from our small experiment--
which you can do yourself--
that you and your friend,
seeing the same object,
may not have the
same perception.
That's where the cognitive
weakness comes in.
If the same-- you can make
experiments with color.
You can make experiments
from the stars.
You can make
experiments on the--
you know, why we
thought astrology
was an important
parameter for a long time,
why people still think.
This sky looks 2D.
Sky looks like it's spherical.
That's a cognitive weakness.
The sky, which expands
so much behind--
looking to you, it's a sphere.
Stars hanging in this
particular sphere
is our cognitive weakness.
Ignorance.
And we stayed with
it for a long time.
We still probably--
you know, whatever
we know now is still weak.
So that is what
you would inquire,
that is there truth
means how long
in knowledge, what timescale
the knowledge may have,
and further, we
can always receive
full cognitive conscious
feedback from our observation,
from our senses.
What he's saying--
again, I don't
know whether it is right
or wrong to talk Shankara.
I think it's a pleasure
to talk Shankara and so
on, because I admire him.
But what he says is that
probably you will never
have access to full truth.
Then he of course
becomes godly and so on,
which you can question.
I didn't show his--
I made a little picture for
him, who did not come out well.
But you know, it
kind of inkjet--
I think it kind of-- you will
kind of snark at this and say,
wow, he shows a religious
person's picture
here and so on.
But I will show you anyway.
It's kind of a typical--
it's some kind of artist
projection of the man,
all right?
But the point is why this man
thinks about this, whether it's
a scientist, a religious
scholar, philosopher,
or has a very high IQ.
I don't know.
But what kind of makes me wonder
that he did think about this
particular knowledge and
ignorance in the scientific
way, that [INAUDIBLE] talks
about in 1923, the same things,
not with that particular
detail, but with experimental--
I don't think he
did an experiment.
It's pure intuition.
okay, what else?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Yes, according
to your lecture,
would it be correct for me
to assume that a machine can
be intelligent, but a machine
can never be knowledgeable?
MISRA: Machine is
conditioned to be
knowledgeable to the point
that to inject knowledge to it.
AUDIENCE: Right, but that makes
it illusional, because there's
always a knowledge beyond that.
So a machine will always
be only delusional,
only be intelligent, but
never fully knowledgeable.
MISRA: Like all we are.
AUDIENCE: So that [INAUDIBLE]
with the Hindu religion.
The Hindus--
MISRA: That is correct.
Yeah.
Yeah, what-- it's not a
Hindu religion from Shankara.
I think the-- suppose you ask
a Hindu religious person some,
he will say he knows it.
AUDIENCE: He knows it.
MISRA: He knows it.
Do a prayer or do
something, something,
you know what to
say the truth is.
But what he kind
of, [INAUDIBLE] says
that what you say the
truth has presented to you,
without having a full
dose of consciousness,
is only perception.
AUDIENCE: It's only a delusion.
MISRA: You take it
with a pinch of salt.
You take it with a
lot of apprehension.
And then--
AUDIENCE: It's the
beginning but not the end.
MISRA: Right.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: The end
is when we're dead.
MISRA: I don't know
whether you would really
see the consciousness.
I think-- I don't know.
I think that to be--
they do like in the
[INAUDIBLE] for that gentleman.
[INAUDIBLE] that doing
the yoga as a technique
to determine consciousness.
They're trying to do experiments
to see whether we can really
see, like when the person is
kind of concentrating strongly,
whether we can measure
the brain function.
So that results will come out.
They're not come out with it.
I think last week there's
some kind of epileptic--
you know, epilepsy-- those
kind of results came out
in neuroscience-- in the
conference last week.
But some more things
will come in next--
they said this is the
year of the brain, right?
Decade of the brain.
Any other question?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
MISRA: Oh, okay.
AUDIENCE: But go to the
other slide, please.
MISRA: Okay.
AUDIENCE: Gentleman on the
left has a [INAUDIBLE]..
She asks you about
a [INAUDIBLE] genes.
And the organizer
asked about [INAUDIBLE]
and your own last
sentence there says
knowledge of the [INAUDIBLE]
is the only truth.
Shankara only are your truth.
And also, therefore,
copying from ancient texts
wherein this pursuit of this
knowledge at this stage--
lore, truth,
knowledge, and love.
They are all mushed together.
It means a dichotomy
[INAUDIBLE]..
My question is, in this
part-- you wil tell me
what you got also, in this
part of attaining that state,
the text is neither
the full [INAUDIBLE]..
Can those bodies-- You
know them, of course.
MISRA: I know, but--
AUDIENCE: Nobody's
ever been [INAUDIBLE]..
MISRA: I don't think we
should get into that,
I don't think the cognition,
like what do you feel--
like what happens when you go
to the objective intelligence?
Like human beings know.
I think that, again, know--
see, this has been
done by children.
[INAUDIBLE]
Have bunch of kids,
10 kids, all right?
You quiz them, how much
they know, what they know.
Then you can find out
where the loopholes are.
For the adults, it's
difficult to do,
because adults have so
much different knowledge.
And an experiment
to say that, look,
where the ignorance level is
and how high the ignorance
level is, what we do
is we do the testing.
We do the exams and so on.
And people flunk.
People move.
Things happen like that.
But that is not cognitive test,
that yes, I know my friend.
I know my father.
I think mother and son,
probably a little different,
because mothers know their
sons, but sons do not
know the-- for example, I tell
you one particular experience
on my part.
I look somewhat
different from my family.
I don't know why.
So we had a person we were
working for in our home,
and she kind of made me
feel that-- and my mom
was a little strict.
She was a very strong
disciplinarian.
So she will kind of always
yell that if I don't come home
at a particular
time or something.
So this woman, for
whatever reason,
she will tell me that,
look, you are not her son.
[LAUGHTER]
And I mean, I was, like, 11,
12 years old or something.
I said, wow.
How do I deal with
this, you know?
How do I deal with this?
What is this?
So I talked to her--
I had-- you know, my
father is a liberal person.
So we had, like--
I called a conference.
My father was there.
Mom was there in this thing.
I sat down.
I said, look, I have something
important to ask, and so on.
And then they said--
they're sitting here.
I'm sitting here.
So I told them.
It was 1959.
I asked them-- I asked my dad,
but how do I know I'm your son?
[LAUGHTER]
How do you know you
are your father's son?
You can do a DNA test now.
Shankara didn't know that.
My point is these
are cognitive issues,
issues that you,
through your perception,
through your senses, you're
receiving information
from the other object to
create an association.
That association, how scientific
it is, how truthful it is,
how objective it
is, is up to you.
What this says-- it
can become objective
if you are totally conscious.
Unfortunately, we are not
all the time fully conscious.
Is there a way to be conscious?
We do not know.
And religion takes over there.
FOERST: I'm sorry,
we have to interrupt.
MISRA: okay.
Very good.
Thank you again.
FOERST: Thank you
so much for coming.
[APPLAUSE]